Jeb Bush has endorsed Ron DeSantis for
president even though DeSantis isn't
even running and this is sort of an
interesting thing you might remember Jeb
Bush from the 2016 Republican primary
the brother of former President George W
bush Jeb has not been a trump guy for a
while and to that extent it's not a big
shock for him to say you want someone
else that someone else is Ron DeSantis
it is a little less common to see
someone in Jeb's position former
governor of Florida uh to come out this
early and to effectively endorse someone
who isn't even yet a candidate but it
could be a sign that the anti-trump
Republicans of the last four to six
years may be finding a home in support
of Ron DeSantis will it be enough to
help DeSantis defeat Trump in a national
primary
I don't know that it will but it'll be
interesting to watch